hey Traders it's Mike from orderflows
here and welcome back to my channel you
know I wanted to make this quick video
for you about my book trading orderflow
that I wrote about 10 years ago and I
want to show you how you can get it for
free you know I've always offered it for
free and it's come to my attention you
know that there are people out there
trying to pwn it off as their own work
or even try to sell it even though it's
been free it's always been free you know
I years ago before I even um started the
orderflows trader uh
software I left JP Morgan and and you
know I wanted some time off and I
started writing a book this was going to
be my contribution back to uh you know
sort of the the trading Community you
know talk about order flow and you know
so it the book is 150 pages okay and
it's just something that you know it's
been my collection of thoughts on
orderflow not just on orderflow itself
what is orderflow but it really Dives
deep into um orderflow it isn't just
another trading guide saying oh you know
you got to have good risk management
take trades like this it's a deep dive
into the critical aspect of market
dynamics that many Traders Overlook
which is basically it is the order flow
and you know if you've ever found
yourself struggling to read the markets
or make sense of you know sort of the
chaos that looks like you know there is
in the market you know I make a lot of
videos um and I've got over 500 videos
posted on YouTube you know over the last
uh seven eight
years and it is uh you know not
everyone's got time to read or sorry
rather to watch you know videos for
unlimited amounts of time and you know
the book was sort of a way that you know
people could you know print it out um
save it make uh their notes with it you
know while they watch uh videos or take
some of my courses right and it's been a
game changer for many Traders I've
gotten email saying you know thanks for
taking the time out to write this book
and you know again you know it was
something that I created for free it
just kills me sometimes that I see
people out there uh basically you
know trying to sell it you know it's
free information orderflow information
is you know to me is the best
information out there so if you want to
get a copy of it okay and again you I've
had this on my website for as long as my
website's been up um you know you can
even watch some of the the webinars that
I do I always show people how to get it
for free what you do is you go to this
link www. orderflows
docomo
HTML okay it takes you to this page um
you know where you just enter your name
first name last name email hit submit
then it's going to take you to the
digital download page right you're not
going to get the actual hard cover copy
of this it's a it's a download okay
and basically you know this is what it
looks like right I've seen people
literally just remove my name from it
and you know in some cases just put
their name on it you know it even talks
about my my background in there and and
I I read it and it just it's the same
background um but it's it's 150 pages
right you can see here's the uh table of
contents right we really cover a lot of
area in the book okay again this was I
wrote this book in 2015 but a lot of the
information that's in there is very
applicable to what um happens now
because again you know orderflow is not
something that is brand new that just
started 20 years ago right if you are
sort of a market historian you know like
like myself I love reading um you know
books from the 1920s even right the you
know sort of most famous book on
speculation is reminiscence of a stock
operator right and what was he he was a
tape reader so you know orderflow is
about reading the tape okay so you know
in trading orderflow right the book
trading orderflow that I wrote which you
can get for free right again just go
there orderflows decom
b.h and it just takes you to that simple
page enter your name and email and hit
submit and you're taken to the book um
you know you're going to learn the
fundamentals of order flow and why it's
important in unlocking market movement
right you're going to learn even
Advanced Techniques um for analyzing
orderflow data so you can spot Trends
before they become obvious to you know
the rest of the Traders or or the crowd
however you want to talk about it you're
going to learn some strategies that you
can apply immediately to recognize you
know high probability trades and you're
going to you know understand how order
flow can give you a significant Edge
over other Traders out there okay and
again you know there's no catch to it
it's free you just go to that page right
here right again the link is down below
in the description and in the comments
just enter your name and email right I'm
not charging you for this you know it's
really it's been my whole concept of
creating this book was my way of giving
back to the trading Community um because
you know when I started out in the
markets you know I started out literally
on the bottom I started out as a runner
and even before that you know how I sort
of got in into that is by taking courses
on the markets you know Market profile
candlesticks U sorry uh technical
analysis um at the CME while I was still
in college so I got to meet people that
eventually worked on the floor that
helped me get a job right because you
know information is Paramount in
understanding the markets okay you know
people go to jail for Insider
information trading but thing is with
order flow it's all right there the
information of what's taking place in
the market is there for you to see right
it's sort of like peeling back the
curtain so to speak and showing things
you know this is one of our trade setups
right here this big red line telling you
to get short is on the orderflows trader
that is the accumulation distribution
tool right it leads a nice short right
because everything that you see on the
footprint is actual trades in the market
and it's important
information okay so again get the the
trading orderflow book it's very simple
you just visit my site and you sign up
right you're going to get instant access
to the book trading order flow again not
the hard cover copy you're going to get
a digital download and again you know it
doesn't matter whether you're a season
Trader or someone that's just starting
out with orderflow all right
understanding orderflow it can be that
missing piece in your trading puzzle
right for a lot of people it really
helps them click and understand what's
taking place in the market so sure to
head over to my website right here this
is the direct link you don't need to go
to you know orderflows decom and start
looking for it just copy and paste this
link or you know the link is in the
description in the comments just click
on it takes you to that page right here
enter your name and email and you're all
set up all right guys so again don't
fall for you know it just kills me that
that I've seen people trying to sell
this book for you know who knows how
much it's been a while since I've
actually looked you know it it's kind of
a it's tiring to go to Amazon and and
fill out you know the paperwork say hey
please take it down you know that I'm
the writer of that book Etc but um you
get it for free all right that was the
whole point of me creating it is to give
back to the trading community so enjoy
the book and you know that's all see you
guys on my next video byebye